[Music]
thank you
first up in the last week 12 000
migrants arrived on the tiny Italian
island of lampedusa more than doubling
its population in one day as European
leaders Panic is this only just the
beginning for the cover piece this week
Christopher Caldwell takes a look at
what is to come he joins me now along
with our columnist Douglas Murray who
writes into his column this week about
how little has changed since 2015 the
last time he was in lampedusa
Douglas and Chris welcome to spectator
TV Douglas take us back to 2015 when you
went July panduza and that was at the
beginning of what we now call the
migrant crisis what did you see
that's right I went there for The
Spectator as it happens eight years ago
now
um and at that point the island which
had about 6 000 inhabitants uh was
getting a lot of boats coming uh I think
just at the time when I was there there
were 1200 people in the uh Asylum Center
there they were trying to get the people
straight off as well as fast as possible
off the island up to Sicily into
Mainland Italy and uh this was something
I then ended up seeing in other places
um as Christopher has in you know the
Isle of Les boss in other Islands across
Greece and that summer of course more
than a million people came illegally
into Europe and uh Europe uh buckled but
was told effectively by its political
leaders that this was a sort of one-off
and I saw then I knew that that was
absolute nonsense what had been
happening on lab producers have been
happening at a lesser extent for some
years and it was clear that a kind of
corridor had wrote
and I think what we've seen this week
this past week as a demonstration of
that well Chris tell us about what has
happened in the last couple of weeks
because you've written about it in a
cover article this week
well basically you've had a steady
volume of of traffic to lampedusa as as
Douglas says but um over the course of
about
five days
um last week uh uh lampedusa got 11 or
000 people which totally overwhelmed
that um that Detention Center in the
middle of the island that Douglas was
talking about and have have actually
overwhelmed public transport and and the
public transport on other Islands as
well and turned it into a bit of a a
political crisis for uh Georgia
Maloney's government Maloney is a is is
a politician who who sort of alarmed a
lot of um uh European journalists when
she came to power a year ago uh uh
because she's descended from the kind of
Mussolini friendly part of the of the
Italian right but in fact it um over the
course of the past year she's ruled in a
very very moderate and I would even say
a center left and pro-european way and
so she's reached a point now where the
main threat to her domestically is from
her actual base from people who don't
believe she's been uh let's say
conservative or or nationalistic enough
and that in turn is sort of kind of uh
it's that is being noticed in other
European countries which are beginning
to have their own immigration
discussions and Chris I want to talk a
little bit more about the political
ramifications in just a second but why
is it that there's been such a huge wave
in the last couple of weeks is it
because of the natural disaster the
flaws that earthquakes has been
happening in North Africa what's is that
being something of a Breaking Point
what's happened
I I don't think it's the um the flood in
Libya although I do think Libya is the
key um Douglas spoke of a of a of a
cordon being breached you know in in
2015 in terms of behavior I think in
this in the case of lampedusa the
important breach of The Cordon
um came in 2011 uh with the uh with the
the the the
euro-american invasion of of Libya
um now people had wanted to people were
very impatient with um more America
Muammar Gaddafi there were reasons to be
impatient with him but he had kept the
um the immigration pressures from Africa
pretty well bottled up there's very
little regulation of these these flows
now it's very catches catch can the
Italians have
um they've been in negotiations with
um the Libyan Coast Guard it's it's it's
just very irregular and so so why were
there 11
000 people this week I don't exactly
know but it may just have to do with the
scheduling of the people who are
traveling trafficking these people or
with something going on deeper in in
Africa but
yeah I I think that I I think that it's
the Anarchy in Libya if you had to name
one factor
um the the proximate cause would be the
Anarchy in Libya and the larger cause is
the absolutely unbelievable demographic
growth in Africa and Douglas I saw your
column in this week also on this topic
it was very interesting because you talk
about why politicians haven't managed to
fix this uh in the eight years since you
you went to lampedusa I mean we've had
you know migration has been top of the
agenda for a lot of people and for
political discourse in the in Europe
you've written the book about it you've
got people like Maloney who come into
government on this platform so why can
politicians like her not fix it
well as Chris has said Chris has written
a book about this as well I mean it's
been a long simmering issue in Europe
and I'd argue The Wider West it's same
miss you America is facing at its
Southern border uh modern democratic
nation states seem to find it hard to
defend their borders certainly in Europe
and North America
um the interesting thing is as you
mentioned that the there is serious
public uh worry about this as there is
in Britain with this with the small
boats coming across the channel at keep
breaking records keep breaking records
uh in Britain our politicians say wig
this is our number one priority and
we're gonna deal with it and then they
don't Georgia Maloney's number one
priority says she wants to deal with it
then she does it and and uh the sort of
online no walls and sort of some of the
conspiracy types at this point say aha
she's been completely bought she's
become a shill of the EU and so on I
don't actually have much time for
Maloney she doesn't have very much time
for me either
um she's not my type a politician but it
I was very struck when she came in I
thought okay well there's one thing
she's really going to be tested on and
so far she's failed there she was in
lampedusa this week alongside Ursula Van
de Leiden and once again Maloney is a
Italian Prime Minister saying we are
taking too much strain in Italy the EU
is not doing enough and I think wow how
many years have I heard that for it's
still true but it still has to be said
and the real explanation I think or one
of the explanations that I give him my
caller and I think hasn't been pointed
out enough is look at what has happened
to some of her Rivals look at what
happened to Mateo salvini who was
interior Minister and Deputy Prime
Minister he's technically a sort of Ally
of Maloney's but also of course a rival
salvini actually did manage to slow down
the boats Landing in land producer and
Sicily how did he do it among other
things by simply so bidding the mission
to land and that included NGO ships and
this is very important because it's not
just the smuggling networks in the
Mediterranean the smuggling networks
work with some ngos to test the
nation-state's borders and there were
NGO ships off the coasts of Italy and
and material salvini refused to allow
them to land now what has happened since
uh it's true that the flow of migrants
reduce but salvini has been twice
prosecuted including by an overwhelming
vote in the Italian Senate to prosecute
him for what kidnapping was the title
the people on the boat by refusing to
allow illegal migrants to land so I give
that example very quickly I'll give
another example ingestoibo who Denmark
was very lucky to have as their
immigration integration minister in 2015
until 2019. ingest toiberg was the the
most important figure to make sure that
Denmark did not make the mistakes Sweden
did in 2015 and taken hundreds of
thousands of people who then couldn't
integrate so Denmark didn't do that
largely because of English feudberg
Waters ingest toyberg's reward been for
keeping her country's borders secure she
has been prosecuted in Denmark she was
sentenced to prison for effectively
defending the borders of Denmark she had
to wear an ankle bracelet so when
Maloney or any other European politician
of right or left is looking at this if
you do the wrong thing and you make sure
that you just allow a constant flow of
illegals into your country you will
retire fine you will be on NGO board
you'll be on Bank boards you'll be just
fine if you do the right thing and
enforce your country's orders you are
likely very likely to face the rest of
your life in the courts well Douglas on
that that law fair is clearly incredibly
concerning especially for democratically
elected politicians but you know to
Chris's point about the underlying
causes things like the 2011 military
intervention in Libya you know how much
can these politicians really have fixed
it you know these these suggestions for
example like the Rwanda plan all of
these different policies which sound you
know on paper dramatic but how much can
that really fix what's you know
something of a structural problem here
you know don't you think that actually
by by blame it on warfare actually we're
giving these policies a bit too much
credit maybe they couldn't have fixed it
anyway
well I think I don't see why it's
impossible to enforce the law
I mean we enforce the law on lots of
other things it's extremely difficult to
get to a country like America or Britain
legally
is it so wildly easy to get into it
illegally I'm sorry it is easy everyone
talks about the perilous Journey you
only have to spend a few hours in a boat
it only costs a few thousand dollars
it's very easy you walk straight in and
you've got a hotel and then you'll get a
work permit as well the legal route is
extremely difficult the illegal one has
become easy I'm sorry politicians can
sort that out I don't think it's a I
don't think it's the world's hardest
Rubik's Cube and Chris what do you think
and also on that point about legal
versus illegal routes you know people
often say if you gave them more legal
routes if you could properly separate
those fleeing political persecution uh
fleeing war and famine from those who
are just looking for you know economic
migration then actually the public will
be more on side you know what about that
argument
that's very very hard to do and I and I
think you know there's a good there was
a good article in um
in ilfolio which is an Italian uh
newspaper this week by a writer named
John Carlo quenzi and he talked about
this shibboleth that all
uh immigration uh politicians all
politicians who talk about immigration
they say that that the real solution to
this problem is to develop Africa to
give migrants more opportunities in the
places where they are
think that if that were easy to do I
think the private sector would be
looking into ways of of doing it the the
fact is
Europe is where the where you connect to
the global economy there there's not
it's going to be it would take a very
very long time
longer than the the Next Generation to
create such an infrastructure uh uh
abroad even if it were possible you're
talking about building up an economy in
an entire in an entire other continent
which which in in Europe has very few
resources now to to to spend on its own
I just don't see how that is possibly
going to happen so it becomes a question
of actually one hates to talk this way
it becomes a question of defending the
border of just sort of physically
keeping people from Crossing that border
and that's it that is a that is a
military problem that's not a it's not a
a courtroom problem or something you
just have to create physical obstacles
to passing and in that we have a kind of
an underlying
um philosophical problem we have a kind
of our governing classes and generally
this is in in most countries this is as
true of the putatively conservative
party as it is of the putatively
Progressive Party there's a there's an
allergy to thinking of politics this way
as this sort of like uh the use of force
to keep people from doing one thing or
another and there's another dimension to
it which is that the rhetoric
surrounding human rights is very hard to
confine to
the rhetoric of citizenship so human
rights rhetoric tends to work against
Republican rhetoric it tends to you know
it's very hard to sort of like establish
that citizens have these rights and then
to answer the question of well okay if
the people on your street have the right
to walk freely why don't the people in
this other country it's a it's a complex
argument but but until we're clear
but as long as we're not clear on it it
it's very easy to game the system can I
add one thing to that city which is ABS
absolutely agree with what Christ has
said but um the argument that you need
to improve the economies of Africa
before you can solve this problem first
of all I mean it's like just
will it ever happen in anyone's lifetime
who knows are you willing to sacrifice
the future of Europe to that personally
not but secondly it's a fallacy Theresa
May used to say this during the
migration crisis she used to say we need
to work at improving the economies in
the countries people are coming from
flat out wrong you can improve the
economies nice thing to do good thing
for those people that doesn't solve the
migration problem in fact a lot of the
evidence shows if if the lifestyle of
the people in a particular country rises
in Africa slightly you get more migrants
coming to Europe because they have the
means to come to Europe so this is all
built on a set of massive fallacies and
to paraphrase something David goodheart
said some years ago the we in in Europe
in particular but America as well have
made two massive miscalculations that
are generational the first is we have
massively underestimated the number of
people who want to come
and in sub-Saharan Africa alone that is
just a bottomless number of people so we
have massively underestimated the number
of people who want to come into our
countries and we are massively
overestimated our ability to integrate
them it's a joke that the people this is
what I realized when I first was on land
producer it's a joke to think that these
people are going to soon become Milanese
Italians or Florentine Italians and
they're going to meld into the culture
of Dante and Picacho and much more it's
a joke they won't their lives will be
very miserable in Italy they will be in
a criminal underclass gang world where
at best they will be selling illegal
handbags on bridges in Venice and
running from the police when they come
the idea that this is the next
generation of Europeans is for the birds
I don't think that intervention to make
Africa more wealthy is something that
the West should be engaging with and as
Chris is suggested you know in some ways
intervention was the very first problem
in the first place but Douglas where
does that line where do you draw that
line when it comes to integration
because do you think it's a volumes
problem do you think that some cultures
inherently find it difficult to
integrate because in the magazine this
week I also have a piece out talking
about the 125 000 Hong kongers who have
come to the UK in the last two years now
what I find from meeting them is that
they tend to be well 70 of them have
University degrees many of them already
speak English they come having sold
their Hong Kong Flats immediately on the
housing ladder here do you think that
integration is a problem for them too or
what is the what is the difference here
that we're talking about
um there's about three things that
really matter in Immigration uh there is
the speed
there is the numbers and there's the
identity
and that's pretty much it
um if you do if you do a difficult
identity to integrate but you do it
incredibly slowly
you can just about cope
do an identity that's hard to integrate
fast and in large numbers it's not going
to work the interesting case you give of
the whole call is it's got many of these
people apart from as you say they've got
University degrees I'm afraid that the
random flow of people across the
southern border of America or across the
soft underbelly of Europe you're not
dealing with people who are massively
over-educated I'm sorry to say but it's
a fact they uh the idea that they speak
the languages of Europe again know and
it's difficult for and it's much more
difficult than it is for somebody from
Hong Kong thirdly people from Hong Kong
as you know I mean many of them have
grown up effectively under a British
system of law among other things that
it's not it so so it's not the hardest
pit to fit into the jigsaw in the same
way there are many people in America who
are in favor of a sort of lacks
immigration policy in America as
compared to Europe because they say well
look it's Hispanics it's they're
Christians almost entirely
um they can fit into our culture
actually a central and southern
Americans don't immediately integrate
into American culture that easily but
it's a better fit than a Muslim Nigerian
trying to fit into France in the 21st
century and again I mean these are just
such obvious things but we've made such
baby steps in recent years of even
acknowledging them that we can't
recognize again speed numbers identity
and the ones people want to speak about
least is identity I mean and Chris just
finally then you know we all know what's
happened to European politics in the
last eight years when this crisis has
not got better it's only got worse are
you writing your piece about the very
many different political shake-ups you
know from Trump to brexit to various
kind of right-wing politicians across
the continent you also write concerning
me that the migrant crisis may only just
be starting that actually this current
wave is going to shake shake European
politics to its cool what do you think
is going to happen from here
well it it just has to do with the size
I think that that of the things that
Douglas was just talking about the key
thing is the size if you got
um if you brought if suddenly one
percent of Florence were made up of of
of migrants it re it probably wouldn't
matter where in the world they were from
over time they could be assimilated but
the numbers in involved particularly
when you go from one side of the
Mediterranean to the other are
extraordinary so this this collapse of
birth rates which we've seen in Europe
probably over the last 50 years you know
it tends to reflect itself in aging it
tends to be camouflaged for a very long
time it's it takes about a couple of
generations before the that you start to
see it in the the the rate of population
replacement but we're at that point now
and the European each successive
European generation is about a third
smaller than the last or at least in a
country like like Italy and then in in
Africa you have a situation where the
continent is is just exploding with
population particularly south of the
Sahara you have a you know there were
there were about
200 million people in sub-Saharan Africa
at the end of um you know the colonial
era say in nineteen
sixty and and and by mid-century there's
going to be over two over two billion
that is from now until mid-century
there's going to be a doubling of
population and that means
you know you have a lot of people trying
to fit into an economy that doesn't have
room for them and they're they're very
they're young they're Dynamic they're on
the move and so we're only at the
beginning of that population growth so
so yes it's going to get get worse
before it gets better but Chris if if
our population is shrinking then we do
have space for the main economy
well it's I mean it's just it's not a
question of just what you have space for
I mean it's a question of the the kind
of society you want to have when you
talk about the numbers when you talk
about the numbers these are large enough
numbers to
become the the culture of uh of of
Europe I mean you you you you you want
to you I assume that one wants to
perpetuate the the culture of Europe
rather than just sort of like uh trade
it off for it for another screen that
Chris don't assume that
all right well well I think that is such
a rich topic for pickings for another
conversation but I'm afraid we've run
out of time there and Douglas Murray
Chris Coldwell thank you so much Tony
inspect taste TV thank you
[Music]
thank you